our situation sucks yes but I'm telling
you more stimulus is not the answer if
you follow any finance YouTube channels
you'd see that all they talk about is
stimulus checks take me Kevin for
instance in just the last seven days he
posted 29 videos of which 25 were about
stimulus checks and this is two months
after the lockdown started
I mean stimulus is good in all at the
start but at one point we have to
consider how much money is the
government actually giving away and what
are the long-term repercussions
so starting off how much stimulus has
even been given out so far well Congress
has passed four stimulus packages which
add up to three trillion dollars
oftentimes when we talk about big
businesses and the government we lose
perspective of how big these numbers
really are so let's just take a step
back and try to understand how much this
really is even if you earned one dollar
every single second that you are alive
which comes out to thirty million
dollars a year it wouldn't take you 100
or 500 or even ten thousand years it
would take you 32,000 years just to make
one trillion so three trillion would
take 96 thousand years or almost 100
millenniums some estimates say that our
entire species has only been around for
that long
furthermore three trillion dollars would
be enough money to fund the entire
economic activity of every single
country in the world for a full year
except five and it doesn't just stop
right here either the House of
Representatives just passed another
three trillion dollars of relief now
this will almost definitely be stopped
by the Senate but the notion that six
trillion dollars of stimulus was even
considered is absurd now you might be
saying America is much different than
all those other countries as the economy
is much bigger
so three trillion or six trillion is
appropriate for the u.s. well then let's
take a look at the 2008 recession and
see how the u.s. responds to that after
everything was said and done they did
spend 2.8 trillion dollars as economic
relief but this was 320 over two years
not six trillion over two months
additionally this was put into several
different mediums to alleviate the
pressure of giving out so much money
taking a look at where this money was
spent we can see the largest portion was
spent on the 2010 tax bill first of all
we should note that this was not even
passed until 2010 and all this
accomplished was extended buses tax cuts
for the middle class it didn't give
people money it just allowed them
Payless next up we have a tarp or the
Troubled Asset Relief Program this was
basically a bailout
for irresponsible banks and didn't hand
out any money straight to people this is
the same case with the Fannie and
Freddie May portion the other portion
was mostly spent on public work projects
like schools and roads so that leaves us
with the two portions the Obama stimulus
and the Bush stimulus again even both of
them put together doesn't even add up to
one trillion
let's first dive into the Obama stimulus
or the American Recovery and
Reinvestment Act out of the seven
hundred eighty seven billion dollars
injected they only gave out two hundred
and sixty blend in direct payments
though these are labeled as direct
payments once again most of these were
in the form of tax credits and
deductions in fact only fourteen point
two billion dollars were actually given
out in checks and these went to Social
Security beneficiaries and veterans
pensions not everyone on the face of the
planet
President Bush spent a lot more on
direct stimulus checks at 120 billion
dollars and these are actually very
similar to how today's checks are
structured but the amount given was
exactly half of what is given out today
as you can see the amount given out over
just the past two months is
unprecedented and is exponentially more
than has ever been given out in US
history or any other country's history
it wouldn't be that bad if we at least
knew that it worked but President Bush's
attempt at this has made it clear that
it is really ineffective first of all it
takes months to even receive this check
for most people and people who received
stimulus checks from President Bush
rarely spent it as intended 32% of
recipients straight-up put this money in
the savings let's just be clear here
this money is not given now to inflate
people savings anyways
48% was spent on paying off debt and
only 20% was actually spent in the
economy again this money is also not
given out to help people pay off debt
either but at least I help these people
in some way unlike the 32% who were just
increasing their
personal savings but this doesn't change
a fact that only 20 cents out of every
dollar given now was spent as intended I
mean it's nice to help people with their
debt but this is a stimulus check it's
meant to stimulate the economy not pay
off debt
so in essence stimulus checks have
historically shown us that they are very
ineffective at helping the economy and
here's the thing the last time 2.8
trillion dollars was given out over two
years with very little directly going to
people the u.s. debt doubled from 10 to
20 trillion dollars of course this was
not all caused by the recession but just
imagine the damage six trillion being
spent in just two months could cause
that is literally more than total tax
revenue over an entire year furthermore
our GDP to debt ratio was in the 60s and
70s back then now we're already above a
100 meaning we have more debt than our
annual GDP I made a video recently going
over the exact economic impact of
stimulus checks and showed that the main
risk was the debt load but given the
situation I did say stimulus checks were
warranted and I still stand by that in
the beginning we were uncertain of how
long situation with last an economic
impact so the first round of stimulus
checks was fine it wasn't the most
effective method to deal with the
economic recession but it did help a
good amount of people but to expect a
second third round $2,000 a month
for everyone making under $130,000 a
year what America is not a socialist
country and we need to stop trying to
make a one but even aside from the
socialist argument giving out more money
would be terrible for the country's debt
and we need to start looking at the
long-term impact rather than short-term
ineffective solutions but that's just
what I think if you guys disagree
feel free to sound off in the comments
but if you guys agree then concern
subscribe me to see more questions logic
answered but until then I'm Hari and
I'll see you guys on the next one